many are still rebounding from the
pandemic shutdowns and the wedding
industry is actually now booming in fact
it's the biggest year we've seen for
vegas weddings since 2015. i had the
chance to talk to some couples who tell
me they can't wait to tie the knot here
in the valley honestly i knew on our
first date that he was the one it's easy
to see samantha michaels and colby wood
are very much in love
newly engaged they can't wait to walk
down the aisle here in las vegas if
we're going to do it might as well do it
right they're one of many couples tying
the knot locally and for the wedding
capital of the world things aren't
looking up we kept love alive in las
vegas clark county held its fifth annual
state of the industry event wednesday to
celebrate the most marriage licenses
they've seen in about 20 years despite
kovid
people want to get married and they
really want to share their lives
together pandemic shutdowns brought a
slight slump last year but chapel of the
flowers ceo donny korestic says pent up
demand and a focus on forever has made
all the difference
it's not the hangover it's not you know
the raunchy weddings these are nice
formal weddings from people all over the
world and if you ask samantha and colby
their special day will celebrate their
true devotion to each other every time i
listen to the song that i'm going to
walk down the aisle too i cry while
experiencing everything in this city
that makes matrimony more than memorable
now clark county is also expected to
mark its 5 millionth marriage license
this year chapel of the flowers says as
more couples are allowed to come here
internationally they expect an even
bigger spike in numbers